avec moi maintenant mon collègue de la
radio michel cej qui a couvert ces
années dorées pour le quotidien le
devoir à l'époque pendant le chercheur
alors on l'a dit il a beaucoup
dépoussiérer cet hôtel de ville on s'en
souvient peut-être pas tellement mais il
a changé vraiment la culture de
l'institution oui absolument
monsieur drapeau avait été leur presque
30 ans et tous relevé du maire il n'y
avait pas de directeur général il répond
de comités du conseil municipal n'avait
qu'un seul celui du nom des rues il n'y
avait pas alors tout instrument un plan
d'urbanisme des choses comme ça tous les
instruments qui font que la base d'une
ville moderne n'était pas là il était à
créer et c'est doré et l'équipe de rcm
qu'ils ont créés à ce moment là
aujourd'hui on vend ces choses là bas il
a trouvé ça très vite aujourd'hui pensée
pour acquis on dirait monsieur drapeau
bon il reste un gentil gentil tu as deux
cracks qui dès qu'ils qui m'a quand même
réaliser de grandes choses qui dirige à
sa façon mais la réalité ce qui se
souvient tellement écouté
l'une des premières choses qu'il a fait
c'est effectivement de faire une période
d'essai de deux questions des citoyens
au conseil municipal
quelque chose qui maintenant se fait
partout donc il aimait les montréalais
est ce que montréal serait la ville
qu'elle est aujourd'hui si on n'avait
pas eu
faire dorer je pense vraiment à ce qu'il
a laissé à la ville son legs patrimonial
il ya deux legs là dedans le premier
s'est regardé le legs de faire bourrer
que le legs de gérald tremblay que je
pense que c'est incomparable avec ce que
j'adorais a décidé d'une part d'autre
part il a convaincu pour le 350e
anniversaire de montréal les
gouvernements c'est à dire de donner des
legs à montréal le budget de la pointe à
callière en état le biodôme et quand
s'il allait à québec ou à ottawa c'est
de convaincre les fonctionnaires que
c'était viable de prendre le vélodrome
olympique une affaire le bio donc
fonctionner la clé c'est la jungle adoré
ça finit par marcher assez bien cette
histoire le la revitalisation du vieux
port toutes ces choses ont été faites
par des gouvernements supérieurs mais à
la demande de montréal ça c'était assez
assez nouveau quand même à l'époque il
ya eu bien sûr il y avait bien sûr les
grands projets avancent à l'expo et
elisa les pics mais les gouvernants
c'est à dire c'est qu'on brûle il
voulait plus aller voir le montréal
montréal avait comme rétabli sa
crédibilité c'est une façon dont on a
parlé de son rôle auprès des familles
l'année léa cousineau conseil exécutif
son intégrité aussi oui parce que bon à
settat de commission charbonneau est
facile de dire de la ville de montréal
est encore en plus d'un bord à l'autre
il n'y a pas eu de scandale du temps
déjà de rire il ya eu quelques petits
problèmes avec une société
paramunicipale 350e anniversaire de la
ville
mais c'était à peu près tout donc de ce
côté là il était un tube est le prochain
merci pour cette mémoire michel le
plaisir